mark ballas injured EEG confirms that  the dancing with the stars pro has  suffered an injury and you may not be  able to hit the dance floor during  Monday night's broadcast mark is paired  up with UFC fighter page Van Sant and  the duo received great feedback from the  judges drain lost monday's season  premiere will be to bring closure eyes  ain't a you Stan I wasn't expecting you  to be so light on your feet she's a coal  mine mark appeared fine over the weekend  both he and page shared this rehearsal  selfie and Mark even mentioned he was  throwing page birthday bash she turned  22 on Saturday page captioned her photo  quotes yeah we're cute eg will keep you  posted on the story as it develops